- I've come to realize,
wow, I'm the human version
of my favorite thesis,
which is whoever is closest
to the consumer wins.
(upbeat dramatic music)
The internet is where our lives will be.
There's a good chance a lot
of the youngsters in here
will literally sit in
a pod eight hours a day
and live their lives.
It's real.
And so I think we need
to really wrap our heads
around what that means,
and so and I also think
we need to wrap our heads around how fast
I think this is actually gonna happen.
(groovy ambient music)
I think about Mariano Rivera,
he's a baseball pitcher,
he's all time, and he's all
time and he had one pitch.
And I really think that's who I am,
I think I'm stunningly one dimensional,
but I'm so deep in this one thing
that it's gonna be able
to bring all of you value,
which is I'm really intuitive
about consumer attention
whether that's in a B to B environment,
whether that's in a B to C environment,
basically all I ever do
it comes natural to me,
it's my interest, it's
what I spend my time on,
it's actually how I see the world.
Like I actually see the
world through how do you make
the decisions that you
make, why do you make them?
To the jokes about politics,
to why he's wearing that shirt,
or why you're wearing your beanie,
like why we use to fashion to communicate,
you know, our facial hair,
like every single thing to me
is communication and it really matters
because this is probably the moment
that attention is being most disrupted
probably since the printing press.
What Guinness Beer Company did by creating
the Guinness Book of World Records,
they created the Guinness
Book of World Records
so people at pubs in the
early 1900s would talk
about silly things like who's the tallest,
reference the Guinness
Book of World Records
which would reinforce the brand Guinness
and make them order Guinness at a pub.
The reason you go to a three
star Michelin restaurant
or resort is because the Michelin
tire company 100 years ago
wanted people in France
and London to drive
outside of the main city
and use their gas stations
and use their tires up
so they started reviewing
restaurants in the countryside
under the Michelin guide
very positively to inspire the wealth
to leave for the weekend.
Media as advertising,
I think the old world
of Guinness and Michelin
is actually the new world.
If you don't live in a cell
phone mobile device world
in your mind and the apps on it,
50 percent of the time
spent on a mobile device
is spent on a social network.
The mobile device is
the most important thing
in our lives, and it grows every day.
And this is 50 percent
overall, it's not 50 percent
of 19 year olds, this is net 50.
If you are not advertising on and properly
on Facebook and Instagram
you're becoming irrelevant
by the second.
If you go to the private schools
in Greenwich, Connecticut,
when you get your birth
year, your license year,
and now what's interesting
is it's going younger,
your expectation is that
your parents don't buy you
a BMW or a Mercedes, your expectation
is that your parents
give you unlimited Uber.
The birthday present of
choice for a 16 year old girl
in Greenwich, Connecticut is
not a cherry red convertible,
it is unlimited Uber.
And the parents would rather have it
because it's the perception of safety.
I couldn't have sold a single
person on this 10 years ago.
10 years from today 14 year old girls
are gonna go into strangers'
cars on a nightly basis
and that's what the
parents want to happen.
Yeah, you could've never sold that.
I've come to realize,
wow, I'm the human version
of my favorite thesis which is,
whoever is closest to the consumer wins.
That's why I'm in a sense winning.
I think one of the most
fascinating things in the world is
the real celebrities are not
as famous as the influencers
anymore, and it's not
even close by the way.
A real celebrity is not as famous
as an influencer on
Instagram, they're just not.
They're just not, like you
can see on every metric
that you want.
Logan Paul sells way more merchandise
than any A list celebrity
and it's not even close.
Way more people watch Youtube vlogs
and follow Instagram celebrities.
I mean go look at the numbers.
Celebrities made a huge
mistake 'cause they were famous
and they were slow to Instagram,
they were embarrassed to go to Instagram
and have a small following
count so they never jumped in
and they just let all
the people get bigger
and bigger and bigger, it was ego.
Content that's bringing
people potentially value,
escapism, entertainment, information
is very different than buy my car,
buy my wine, buy my blouse.
It's just literally positioning.
Grey Goose at Wine Library
is 32 dollars a bottle,
feels one way.
Grey Goose at Lava at a table
feels a totally different way
and is 500 bucks.
It's context.
Cardinalships are super interesting to me
'cause I'm fascinated by what
I call expiring employees,
meaning if there's somebody
sitting in a car dealership
waiting for a human being to come in
they could be doing something.
So for me what they could
be doing is searching
a 10 mile radius on
Twitter, somebody will Tweet
that they popped their tire
and they're on the side
of the road, in theory that salesperson
could jump into one of
your cars, drive over,
change the tire and drive them to work,
which then would create word of mouth
by maybe the local news
would pick up on it
and now you're building brand awareness.
There's so much smart shit you can do
once you make the switch.
Creative is the variable of success.
Once you make the switch
that this is the only world
now all of a sudden you do the homework,
now all of a sudden you
spend 15 hours reading
on Google how do I create a filter,
how do we run ads on Facebook,
how do you sell cars.
Like how do you sell
cars on Facebook, enter.
Do you know how much
information is there for free?
Unlimited.
(groovy ambient music)
Go to Spotify, maybe even
Apple Music right now
if my team can move fast before
we post this on the podcast,
open Spotify, search Monday
to Monday, T, O, Monday,
scroll all the way to
the bottom, playlists,
follow that playlist and get straight fire
every Monday morning.
♪ Honestly I think that
24/7 a understatement ♪
♪ To my day today, if ain't no
way then I will make a way ♪
- Hey Gary.
- How are you my friend?
- I'm doing phenomenal, still.
- Good, still off the high of that moment?
- Oh yeah.
- [Gary] Are you trying to figure out
how to make that more successful?
- Yeah.
- Let's go, let's go a different route.
Shane I'm gonna fly you to
New York City to VaynerMedia
and you're gonna spend a
day with me and my team
and we'll show you what to do.
(applause and cheering)
Good, I'm glad we finally made it happen.
How have you been?
- I've been doing phenomenal.
- Good.
- I've been working on my online presence
so far as Instagram.
I'm not sure if I'm doing
it right or whatever.
- Well what's your Instagram,
while you're signing
I'll look at your Instagram a little bit.
- Oh it's shanex1975.
- I just followed you brother.
shanex1975.
So what can I help you with in my time?
I know you're gonna be spending time
with the team observing.
- Yeah.
- But obviously you wanna
build your personal brand up.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And so ultimately to do
more books and more speaking
and make a living that way.
- Yeah, ultimately
that's what I want to do.
- I love it.
- Is write books and motivate
people and inspire them.
- Shane, help me understand, what do you,
when you said it was your side hustle now,
do you have a side job?
Do you have an actual job right now
and this is still your side hustle?
- Yeah.
- I figured.
- Yeah, I wash dishes.
- I remember, I remember still.
So how much time a day does that take up?
- A little over seven hours sometimes.
- And so how much time
are you able to work
on your brand and your side hustle?
- You know, for a couple hours before work
I sit there and you know?
- What are you doing?
- Replying, responding to people's,
people commenting and so forth online.
- On Facebook and Instagram, where?
- On Face, yeah.
- But you're not getting
too much engagement on,
you're not getting a lot of
comments on your posts, right?
- Right.
- So yeah, you don't, it's not taking up
a lot of time for you to comment back
because there's not a
lot coming in, right?
- Right.
- So then what are you,
are you seeking out
conversations then?
When you say in the morning
you're spending time.
- Oh well.
- Are you leaving comments?
- Actually I've been
spending a lot of time
watching your videos
and getting, you know?
- Motivated.
- Basically doing research.
- Understood, which is
okay, which is okay.
Have you started going
into other people's content
and becoming a bigger
part of the community?
I believe that if you leave your two cents
and let's call this the 18 cent strategy,
let's make it up right here on the spot.
I want you to start deploying
the 18 cent strategy.
You're gonna drop a $1.80
a day, two cents at a time,
nine top posts times 10
different hashtags every day
and that will massively
build up your audience.
You're gonna leave a $1.80 in karma,
a $1.80 in community, a
$1.80 in your thoughts.
You're not gonna spam.
- Yeah.
- I see people on my account all the time,
follow me, follow me,
you're not gonna spam.
- Yeah.
- You're gonna part of
the gratitude, thankful,
be present, choose happiness,
positivity community.
- Okay.
- Shane everybody wants to talk.
- Yeah.
- The way to win is to
listen and then contribute.
Everybody wants to talk,
everybody wants to put a picture
of themselves like you
looking cool running.
- Yeah.
- But I looked at your social
and just like 99% of people
watching, nobody's listening yet.
That's okay, that's
not discouraging to me.
Nobody listened to me at first either.
Let me say it one more
time, for over a year
nobody watched my god
damn shows on Youtube.
The way to be discovered is to
either put our great content,
have one great piece of content, go viral,
and then everybody discovers you.
Or the way I like it, become
part of the community.
You will pick up three
to four followers a day
that are meaningful.
That means you'll get 100
meaningful people in a month.
That means you'll put a piece of content
and if one of 'em is special that's,
it's just amazing how it works.
But this will keep you fresh.
You know what's also great about it?
The hidden great part of this,
you're gonna get exposure,
you're gonna get some followers,
you're gonna contribute, and
be a great community member.
But you're also gonna learn
because you're gonna watch
and consume 90 pieces of content
that are doing well on Instagram,
which is then gonna inspire
and help you strategize
the content that you yourself
are gonna put out on Instagram.
That's a good use of three hours a day.
In the morning, during your lunch break,
while all the dishes are drying,
when you get home, tried
and true, every day,
gratitude, empathy, kindness,
striving, motivation,
motivational Monday,
you pick the hashtags,
they're unlimited, and
they all have a top nine.
Let's do one together.
And Shane, nothing trumps the work.
You can be here for a
whole week, a whole day,
you can spend your life with me.
What's that old adage, right?
Show a horse how to
drink the water, right?
Or show somebody how to fish.
Right, they never have the, help me here.
- [Audience Member] It's if
you show someone how to fish.
- They'll never have a day in life that.
- [Audience Member] I
literally did that yesterday,
and I was like what's
that fucking quote again?
- Bottom line is instead
of giving you some fish
to eat right now I'm gonna teach you
how to eat fish the rest of your life.
I want you to do that 89 more times today.
- Right on.
- I'm being dead serious.
- Yeah.
- I'm glad you're here man.
- Yeah, I'm glad, I'm glad.
- It was a really good moment for me.
- Yeah, thank you very much.
Can I get a selfie?
- 100 percent.
That's a good post for Instagram.
- Right on.
(groovy dramatic music)
- I need some coff.
(groovy ambient music)
So let me give you a piece of advice.
Gather as much attention as you can,
as much as you can, because
you're gonna trade on that
to your point.
No matter what comes out of
your guys' collective mouth,
we're gonna start a beverage business,
we're gonna start, we're
gonna create our own,
we're gonna create our own label,
we're gonna start a, we
want a Beats by Dre moment,
it's gonna be that
fucking red ass fly thing.
Like whatever the fuck
you guys are gonna say
all of it is gonna trade
on one currency, attention.
The fuck am I doing?
I'm just gathering so much attention
and then I get to deploy it.
My K Swiss collab outsold
Future and The Weekend.
That makes no fucking sense.
Like this much sense.
Because I'm more attention
than people realize
and my attention's deep,
those guys have more attention
than I do, but it's
scattered on other things
and there isn't that, there's
connection, that'd be unfair.
But like.
- Focused.
- That's right.
What I want for you and
anybody else in your position,
this young, this much talent,
this kind of collective crew,
you know to me it's like,
it's why I always thought
Drake was playing it right,
and here's what's smart
about what Drake did and I
had no idea if this is what
they thought, I just don't know.
But the volume of projects that he put out
speaks to my thesis
which is when you're hot
fucking like when you got the best hand
fucking keep playing it.
I think the other thing
that I'm obsessed with
is who you collaborate with.
Louis Vuitton and Under Armour and Reebok
and everybody else, they're all
in deep fucking shit my man.
That game is over, I'm glad
your reaction, they're all dead.
- We were just talking
about that yesterday.
- Guys, guys, they're all dead.
Here's what that means.
Instead of worrying about that right now,
go deep as fuck into attention grabbing,
pop back out in 24
months, you'll get pieces
of equity in Nautica.
Fuck a deal, just a little
more patience right now
at the time that it's the hardest
because you've been fucking
eating shit and now you're here,
but you're here.
Do you know what I mean?
- I know what you're saying.
- And what's crazy is
right now is why everybody,
this is why most people don't win,
this is the time that you
go even more shit eating,
not the reverse.
And it's so counter
cultural, 'cause you guys
were all talking about this
day for fucking every day
for the last 2,000 days in a row,
and now you're here and
you think you're here,
and it's like no, no, no.
And that's what I did, I
fucking invested in Facebook,
Twitter, Uber, everything,
I was here, I did it.
And I decided to build
a client service agency,
go into clients and eat shit
in the prime of my career.
So I'm giving you advice I took
and now I'm really here,
and I'm still not really,
you know eventually like
the longer you can hold
your breath, you win.
I'll give some love, I'll
get some followers for you.
♪ Money all around me ♪
♪ I look like I'm the man ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
- Hi.
- I got a weird handshake so I'll do it,
let's do a normal one.
- That is my normal one.
(laughter)
- I like the normal one.
(groovy music)
- Long day of meetings
here in headquarters.
- I gotta tell you this
'cause this is my son,
he'll kill me if I don't write,
so I sent him this, okay?
He goes I watch all of his speeches,
what is he training on?
And I said how to fuck the competition
and what they've done on
social, blah, blah, blah.
And then he goes I love that guy,
please get a pic with him
and tell him I say thank you
for existing to fire me the fuck up.
- What's his name?
- His name is Christian.
So we have to do, we have to send him,
you have to send him like a little clip.
- We're going video first.
Christian, I got a serious
question Christian,
why is your paps here and you're not?
Where the fuck are you Christian?
See you soon.
- All right, thanks a lot.
- All right, let's sit down.
The question becomes, you know,
what are we talking about here?
There's a very big
difference between going out
to you know, Vegas for
the weekend to hook up
and go to Tao every night versus going out
to networking events or
even going out socially
as a proxy to the
networking that you need.
For example, booking
agents and the people,
like I know where people
that book talent go,
they're not where you and
your friends want to go.
They're two very different places.
They're very different
bars, the timing of when
they hang out are different.
If you're asking me should
I go out to, you know,
you know, you know, a club at
one o'clock in the morning,
I'd be like no, that's you actually,
if you, you know, that's you going out.
If you're asking me
should you go to The Grill
at six PM where you
could be getting a drink
just working on your phone
and the person next to you
is booking people for a
runway place for real.
Should you do that, yes.
There's a very clear difference
between work and play.
I'm going out to play but
maybe I'll run into business.
- [Audience Member] I don't
wanna play, like that's the.
- Respect, so don't,
but networking matters.
You know what's amazing
about the modern world?
This fucking thing.
You know, go into The Grill in 1984
and hoping to find a talent agent
or whatever the fuck is on
the play sucked because,
because you sat there
like a fucking jerk off
if nothing was happening.
You'd go to The Grill
in 1984, you'd sit down,
and you'd have to like look around
and like people are thinking
you're trying to hit on them.
Like it would be convoluted.
The fact that you can go
there and just start working
on your phone while you have a cocktail,
and if it plays, it plays, but if not
you basically just had a two
hour meeting with yourself
on your work, you could've
done that at the coffee shop,
you could've done that laying in your bed,
you could've done that right here.
That's fucking incredible, that is how,
that's the subtleties that we
don't give this credit for.
Got it?
That's big time.
(mellow ambient music)
- You're Gary, right?
- I am.
- I'm Raz.
- Hi Raz.
- Introducing myself, I went to your,
your talk at the Synergy
Global Forum two weeks ago
and I know who you are, and it was like
the most amazing thing ever.
- Thank you.
- And now I follow you, my
whole family follows you.
- Thank you.
- And now I'm like oh that's.
- Thank you Raz.
- But I work at L'Oreal.
- Oh very cool.
- So I was like it was so
funny 'cause I was like
oh my gosh, Vayner's in my building.
- That's awesome.
- How didn't I know about this?
But you were amazing, like seriously.
- Thank you so much.
- Like super inspiring.
- Thank you so much, that's awesome.
- So I didn't mean to like get in.
- Thank you, no worries, no worries.
Thank you so much for saying hello Raz.
(uplifting ambient music)
We're in Madison Square Garden.
We're branching out Jamal Adams.
(uplifting ambient music)
See ya.